let's talk about everybody's favorite TV
grandmother Barbara Walters it was
announced last week out of nowhere
deadline.com said she was retiring they
said she was given up the view all the
ABC gigs etc etc and then the weekend
past and then Barbra jumped on the view
and said not so fast let's take a look
so there were many reports last week
saying that I was retiring from ABC and
there was an assumption that I would be
making an announcement today and the
paparazzi was outside of my home we have
a lot in common Justin to life however
Here I am and I have no announcements to
make
but if and when I might have an
announcement today I would do it on this
program I promise and the paparazzi guys
you will be the last to know all right I
guess it's gonna take a little longer
for me to replace barber at the view um
guys what what's everyone's fascination
with the view first because I feel like
not a week goes by that we don't hear
something about those five crazy ladies
bill what do you get I don't know it
just become an institution rights the
first show of its kind but you know
they've been able to keep it in
all-female institution so I guess people
go there for for that voice but you know
it's such a cushy job for her like I
said I thought she wants retired she
basically been retired how many retired
by Matt eyerman her retirement it's just
like an old woman showing up and talking
and it's like I rightly what surprised
when I heard she was 83 she looks great
for 83 yeah and people say oh come on
just leave peacefully i would leave
peacefully it's her show she started it
she still you stay in that you stay
Barbara yeah what do you guys think
though about this idea that the
network's I mean this is happening with
leno as we speak that the network seem
to be like leaking things and it's also
with successful things because leno's
ratings are still the best and they're
rakin in the dough the view is one of
their most profitable things over at ABC
so why is it that the networks have this
like self-fulfilling prophecy that they
want to destroy the things that are
making them can i don't know i don't
know if it's a publicity stunt I don't
know I one of my favorite parts of the
report was that they were waiting for
her publicist to go to town give me a
break like honestly Barbara Walters
she's a very strong independent woman
she's successful the view is her show
she's going to leave and retire when
she's damn well ready and you know what
like you said she disappears for like
months at a time from the view yeah I'm
from ABC special she's not there day in
and day out she could get the chicken
pox a couple months of she's gone for
like two months with the chicken pox
that woman is limited like the Barbie
late oh yeah the chicken pox look around
right so I mean I they can do whatever
they want but I don't think they can
force like a Jay Leno or a Barbara
Walters to go into retirement if that is
the case I don't buy it but if that is
the case like people are speculating I
mean Jay Leno and Barbara Walters are
here to stay yeah do you think these
networks just have this bizarre or is
this just all publicity I mean it's
just more publicity it's difficult it's
difficult to tell if you know this is
just something that's going to get a
bunch of staplers throughout it in turns
heads and people are just screwing up
and leaking the wrong releases or if
this is you know the intern
Machiavellian hatchet job by whoopi
goldberg or god knows what um and but
you know there you always have to
account for the possibility that
networks are trying to create tension
and publicity in a very odd way and that
their stars are in on it completely and
we all know that you know nikki Finke
and Deadline Hollywood there no stranger
to this and you know I think there's
Barbara Walters we all choose into far
too powerful a position at that shown
with ownership to be pushed aside with
you know non voluntarily so this was
either a big mistake and got a bunch of
people fired or it you know it was done
completely choreographed and Bob Iger
sitting there laughing his ass off I
wonder how many people tuned in to the
to her announcement today yeah yeah I
mean it was the first everyone was
talking about it all weekend right we
probably had the most eyeballs exactly
today uh what do you guys think though
is this just you know is Barbara she
can't go anywhere unless she wants to as
you're all saying but are they are they
leaking this because ultimately they
want to go younger so you sort of put it
out there then she has to respond and
then it's like that's your way of sort
of edging her out it could just be you
know publicity stunt for uh a little
uptick in uh in in ratings you know but
I don't think anyone really wants to see
her go idea yeah bring about it yo the
only reason that would like to hear it
goes because I be it doesn't seem like
what kind of uh what type of Conclave is
convened in order to pick her successor
is it would be such a huge big deal to
see ya would do the celebrity interviews
make them cry she's like the only one
that can do that but I think she might
have retired from those things no say
she's not gonna do the ocean
with larry peterson yeah I want to see
so all right so my last question on this
is there anything forgetting
entertainment and networks and all that
in 2013 in America it is loyalty to your
company or your company's loyal to you
loyalty to you is that does that exist
anymore no we're all just out front it's
gone I've done I would yeah I can't
really trust anybody and we work for the
same company so here-here's different
the big networks absolutely yeah up at
this class she's going for that chair
day she has this year bonobos calm is
the official outfitter of the Ruben
report used code trr 20 to get this
shirt and these jeans